ja ich brauche jetzt ganz schnell was zu
essen dann macht ihr einfach auf 5000
und zack ist das alles fertig meine
damen und herren elisa unglaublich das
ist doch einfach nur krass kollege das
klare ja gut egal wenn man alter senden
eine feindschaft guckt auch noch wohin
ich meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen zu einer neuen folge
minecraft facts die sollte eigentlich
vor zwei tagen konnten die kam da aber
nicht weil ich da den ganzen tag weg war
ich war da in hamburg und überall
jährigen uni sachen unserem ganzen
schweiz deswegen hatte ich da einfach
gar keine zeit deswegen kommt die heute
ich versuche es nächsten dienstag zu
schaffen das wird wieder zufällig am
mittwoch noch eine abi klausur schreibe
ich versuche es zu schaffen sie kommt
auf jeden fall wöchentlich eine folge
minecraft aber ich würde sagen wir
fahren direkt an mit denen facts und
zwar spiele ich gerade in der version
angezeigt
14 17h oder so das funktioniert
allerdings auch in 14 w 18b alles was
nach 14 17 14 wir 17 14 wie 18b meine
lieben frauen spielen der neuesten
version
es funktioniert wirklich in allen
versionen auf 14 17 a
und zwar kann man die geschwindigkeit
verändern wie schnell sachen wachsen
das heißt ihr seht jetzt hier ein
bisschen blöd im wasser ihr seht ihr
beispielsweise alle möglichen sachen
aufgebaut ein kollege so bleibt uns erst
mal klein würde sonst effekt der nicht
wir sehen hier kakteen wir sehen hier
zieht wir sehen hier zuckerrohr
ich glaube das ist kürbis und das ist
mir lohn oder andersrum habe ich extra
am platz gelassen mit da was wachsen
kann und ich habe schon zwei bereiche
gemacht und zwar achtet jetzt noch diese
sachen ihr seht ja okay das ist alles
ein bisschen doof das dauert immer so
wenn ich dann irgendwie macht was anbau
oder sagen wir ich viel zweifel und ihr
wollt jetzt unbedingt jetzt ja ich
brauche jetzt ganz schnell was zu essen
da macht es hier einfach auf 5000 und
zack ist das alles fertig meine damen
und herren dieser unglaublich das ist
doch einfach nur krass also danke ich
werde am ende nochmal eine person
erwähnen die mir da richtig coole sachen
geschickt hat wenn ich das einfach auf
rennoptik speed ich kann es auch auf
weiß nicht ich weiß nicht wie hoch das
geht das funktioniert genauso wie wenn
ich jetzt theoretisch wenn ich jetzt mal
hier warten ein dich will ich wenn ich
jetzt mal einen zeppelin hinsetze der
wird gleich in die höhe gehen wie sonst
was also wenn ich jetzt auch das
intelligente das sind diese links und
verdammt die mutter wollte so ein hier
nicht dass wir hier sehen
der baum muss wirklich eine andere das
ist krass das ist unglaublich das muss
man so sagen
ich kann auch einfach mal
game 0 random six speed also dass der
komanis marienthal eingeben
ich gehe jetzt mal 10.000 1 4025 das
ganze auch wenn ich so fluid blogs
setzte das ist das ist einfach nur irre
beim wasser ist das besonders krass wenn
ich jetzt mal theoretisch schaut mich
setzt hier ein wasser hin alles voll mit
wasser und jetzt will ich da einen baum
hinsetzen zack der baum ist da setzt der
lage hin
zack und bau muss weg das ist
unglaublich um ein gott freundlich
wollte gerade die kakteen ihr abbauen
laut wiso dran vorbei und die wachsen
vor allem was geht man ein klavier und
kaputt machen aber das ist war so krass
auch wenn ich ihnen allerdings abbaut
da wächst einmal direkt alle darstelle
dass man das ist unglaublich das ist
einfach nur irre das ganze machen wir
wieder auf den üblichen stand indem wir
einfach einen tick speed 1 eingehen weil
dann ist das ganze wieder auf einem
normalen level und wenn wir zum beispiel
10.000 eigentlich im handel als 10.000
mal so schnell also nur damit ihr auch
wisst wie man das wieder zurück setzt
luca ist total dumm hört nie auf luca
das ist nicht geben dieses rennen text
auf 1 1 wäre ein drittel die
geschwindigkeit sondern dass es drei ich
hab' ich kapital vertan
also müsst das auf 3 setzt damit ihr
wieder auf der normalen geschwindigkeit
seid wenn ihr das auf einsetzen würde
würde alles ein drittel mal so schnell
gehen dass ein baum wächst ein drittel
mal so lange das wäre krass dann wer
wasser so in slow motion aber okay ich
wäre nicht locker wenn ich das ich
machen würde
das wäre wasser jetzt in ein drittel
geschwindigkeit und wenn wir das ganze
mal mit lover machen dann wird eine ttv
der zweite effekt würde mir zugesendet
von peter nig strom zwar ist es etwas
was mit dem sinken zu tun hat ihr kennt
jetzt ich stehe einem blog das ist
beispielsweise lava und die will
diamanten abbauen und ich nicke und kann
dann einfach erkenntnis ich stehe quasi
neben dem blog sneaker aber indem ich
auf dem bock drauf bleiben wenn ich
weiter nach vorne laufe passiert nix
wenn ich loslasse also wenn ich zum
beispiel bin und loslassen kann es sein
dass sich allerdings dann da rein falle
also ich kann zum beispiel hier auch
wenn ich ohne es neben ein bisschen die
langlauf geht das auch aber mit siegen
ist das immer besser und ich komme dass
ein bisschen weit herum
ihr kennt alle das liegen dann
funktioniert bei allen möglichen blöcken
ich habe zum beispiel ein schwamm ich
hab mir so eine komische mauer die
einfachen halten blog also man ist ja
bei einer mauer man steht einmal so ein
stückchen höher als wenn man so
offenbarte ich zeig euch mal als wenn
ich hier auf seinem blog darauf stehen
würde
hier funktioniert ja überall das
nickenig fall von diesem blog nicht
runter auch nicht bei solchen etwas
höheren blöcken also ordentlich bei
einem zaun oder anderen bleibt halt
andere eigenschaften haben wie wir zum
beispiel den zaun und eine mauer
allerdings bei diesen blöcken ich glaube
das sind die einzigen blöcke ärzte nur
geschrieben bei einer kiste es gibt aber
noch andere von zählt das nicht diese
blöcke
deswegen habe ich hier auch extra einen
zaun und eine mauer hingesetzt mal bei
so einer mauer beispielsweise die ist ja
kleiner aber man läuft darauf in die
höhe sondern muss sie auch höhere aber
man kann trotzdem darauf sneaker
allerdings bei solchen blöcken die zum
beispiel noch halb so grosses nickel und
ich kann da einfach runterfallen oder
bei einer kiste die eigentlich genauso
groß ist dies ein ganz kleines stück
kleiner als normale blog kann man auch
unter fall genauso wie bei diesem
entscheidenden table bei diesen dingen
wo man ende augenrollen packt bei also
eine andere kiste bei dieser ender
christliche kannst du auch runterfallen
und halt bei allen möglichen von diesen
crazy platten hier also das ist
eigentlich ganz interessant das ist
quasi ein paar blöcke gibt auf die man
einfach nichts nehmen kann und das ist
bestimmt auch ganz klar trick weil es
gibt zum beispiel beim
diesen heißen die dungeons heißen die
dungeons ich weiß gar nicht wo man diese
sachen hier hat wo man dann diese augen
rein tut wo man quasi drüber läuft dann
ist da immer so ein lover see
darauf kann man wenn ich es nicht und
dann könnte kann schon sein dass in die
lava fällt es halt ein bisschen scheiße
ist allerdings gut zu wissen dass das
ganze auf kisten et cetera nicht
funktioniert dann kann dich peter
freunde für den dritten fact habe ich
mir mal wieder eine andere welt hier
erstellen lassen von dem lieben law der
mit ein bisschen die arme gegriffen hat
der meidericher da machst du dir alles
kaputt hier
danke an sarah für den facts und zwar
dass es nicht so ausschlaggebend ist
aber was glaube ich gut wäre zu wissen
wenn man vom partien hintereinander
setzte kennt es mit sicherheit wenn ihr
einfach ein game hotel und ihr wollt
alle einfach alles in luft sprengen
wir haben es ja schon manchmal gemacht
ich und komme wenn mir meine adventure
map gespielt haben
man kann tnt halt in seinem abstand
zueinander setzen kann das auch so ein
bisschen weiter weg setzen
dann kann ich hier ein zünden und ihr
werdet sofort sehen die anderen
entzünden sich gleich mit damit man
nicht wirklich jedes einzelne tnt von
alleine zu entschuldigung schafft oder
hinten ich habe dir weh getan
du bist auch sichtlich verwirrt darüber
das sieht man schon läuft einfach in
alle richtungen kollege das klare ja gut
egal wenn man altersrenten dass das
schafft auch noch wohin gut egal widmen
wir uns wieder den wichtigen sachen
jetzt will das aber das tut mir leid ist
die schafe getötet habe egal ich will
ich das allerdings mal hier im wasser
zeigen dass es egal ob ich das da und
mach' oder hier
wenn ich hier tnt setzte die einfach im
wasser sind also in die wasser oder
feuer und zünde ich hier einst an
da macht das vertritt in diesen knall
schaden auch wenn ich im game 1 0 wäre
die schaden bekommen des schubs mich weg
es macht allerdings keinen schaden so
wie ich das letzte mal in einer folge
gezeigt habe es macht außerdem nicht
diese reihen
folge also wenn ich quasi jetzt die mine
anzünden wird dieses hier nicht
angezündet obwohl es direkt in dem radio
steht und eigentlich auch weggeklickt
werden sollte also das ganz gut zu
wissen und diese scharf da hinten das zu
recht
das steht ja echt total perplex einfach
rum das denkt sich auch sofort die suppe
und tee oder nein komme ich hätte dich
heute wichtig halte dich natürlich ich
werde dich bleibt bestehen so freundlich
bin jetzt gradmesser für den vierten
fekter ich hab jetzt so eine kleine bude
gebaut gerät schon ich kenne beide bern
ich bin ein mädchen ausgerichtet mit
diamant falls du irgendwas schief gehen
sollte
hier soll bald gas und ich gehe jetzt
mal in den game mode 0
das heißt wenn ich irgend einer von
diesem chance gab's gleich entdecken
sollte der dahin jetzt beispielsweise
erschießt mich ab mit so einem ding
es geht allerdings nichts kaputt sonst
geht immer was kaputt ihr seht auch
beispielsweise ich jetzt gerade das glas
kaputt gegangen allerdings bleibt es
auch dabei
jetzt hat er genau in mich rein
getroffen poppelsdorf wird nicht von
gast schüssen kaputt gemacht das heißt
wenn ich alleine trifft aber auch genau
das ist ja unglaublich
also ich kann jetzt hier beispielsweise
mal kommissionen machen alter der der
man richtig gute range das ist ja mal
richtig stark ich könnte aber
theoretisch alles aus kombis dann
einfach machen
wer nämlich jetzt noch mal sehen sollte
hallo hier irgendwer beispielsweise
letzter coup ist ohnehin und es gibt nur
das glas kaputt cobblestone wenn ihre
arbeit und ihr seht gas macht einfach
cobblestone hallo wenn er nicht mal
sehen sollte jetzt marco bis anhin
nichts passiert durchkommt ist es
passiert nichts die kennen die können
von mir aus hier mich angreift wie sonst
was finde ich hier mit cobblestone
einfach rum hantiere und mir auch so
eine kleine schutzmauer einfach schnell
bauer das dauert jetzt auch relativ
lange bis der schuss eigentlich das ist
jetzt nicht so wie sonst wohl der fall
auf einmal einfach kommt dann seht ihr
einfach da kommt so ein ding macht euch
eine mauer
und dann wird das hier abgeblockt also
das ist eigentlich super geil was halt
immer noch ein bisschen tag ist wenn man
einen von diesem typen hier angreift
geht gleich die ganze freude dann würde
ich sagen war es auch schon wieder mit
der heutigen folge tschuldigung
nochmaligen chips nicht sinne dass die
folge heute ist die folge am donnerstag
kam
ich war halt wirklich davor die ganzen
tag immer weg und hab's halt erst jetzt
geschafft defekt sind ja trotzdem die
gleichen die waren und diese folge sehr
sehr geil noch mal danke an nur zwilling
der mir den ersten fekter zugesendet hat
mit diesem mit diesem speed dingens dass
man minecraft viel schneller und viel
langsamer machen kann das ist auf jeden
fall eine richtig geile sache wie
gefällt euch das wenn ich solche kur
infekts am start hat die mir von euch
zugeschrieben werden
anton crafter twitter.com oder ab in die
kommentare damit da lese ich die auch
immer sehr häufig also das ist auf jeden
fall super wenn ihr mir die ganzen
versendet weil dadurch liebt diese serie
von eur 6 wenn euch etwas gefällt dann
lassen bewertung das schaffen wir
irgendwie weise nicht 3000 er schon eine
killer zahl weil ich habe echt mühe
gegeben das ganze mal wieder zu
bearbeiten
jetzt nämlich ein bisschen dahin gesetzt
und nicht also alles einfach so ein kann
durch doping ja mal ein bisschen kacke